hey so I was thinking today about
probably what the title of this video is
down below whatever you know all right
so what do you really need to be a
programmer what do you need to know and
why is why do people have so much
trouble why's it so hard you know I was
thinking about these sort of things why
are there so few of us in general and
when one of us you know why are we also
like cocky when we are programmers well
there's really only there's like two
things there's like two things you need
to know about about this or we'll say
there's two sides to programming there's
two like really important things that
make you a programmer and a lot of
people have one of them but don't have
the other and it's something I'm
starting to see more and more and I kind
of I know which ones my strengths and I
know which ones my weakness of these two
sides and the two different things are
there's like okay so if you if you look
way back in the history of wind
programming started when computers were
first starting to be a thing back in
like 50s 60s 70s the very first
programmers were not actually
programmers they were just like really
smart people mathematicians they were
business people they were well-educated
people and and they were also really
devoted and there were people that were
willing to spend a lot of time and a lot
of effort on a problem and just stay
committed they weren't like fly by the
sea or pants type people they were
really thinking about things and and
then programming King later the whole oh
let's get a degree in programming King
came later after like computers were
starting to get big
so the point of this is programming is
kind of a fad word being a programmer
isn't what actually I always say this
it's not what actually makes you a
programmer or someone worth hiring as a
programmer you saying I have a degree in
something a degree in programming or I'm
really good at programming doesn't
really mean much what means a lot more
is I understand the algorithms I'm good
at math and I'm good at problem-solving
that means a lot more than I'm a
programmer this is a subject I've been
thinking about quite a bit so the two
different sides there's like there's a
you're a devoted person person who's
good at math and good at problem-solving
and good at coming up with solutions to
weird problems that don't have an
obvious solution and then there's oh I
know this language like I know job I
know C++ I know JavaScript none of that
really means crap like I remember really
good at C++ that's like my thing I've
been studying it I've been studying the
language I've been studying everything
that does and often there were a lot of
times when I got stuck on things and I
didn't understand them and I was like
but I get all the syntax I understand
what it's doing I understand what the
code is doing I understand the pointer
but there's something here I'm not
wrapping my head around and it's because
my weakness is the other side I tend to
be pretty good at problem-solving I tend
to be pretty good at coming up with
innovative solutions I tend to be pretty
good at that sort of thing but maybe
there was a bit of lack of commitment I
give up a bit too quickly and go play
video games or something so that that
tends to be more of my problem
or I don't know the math quite well
enough I've always been pretty good at
math but I'm not like the best
mathematician in the world or anything I
can usually like just look up stuff or
know a pretty good general thing yeah
that's not a good explanation but the
point is I'm not a mathematician and I
consider myself a programmer and I'm
starting to see that this is kind of a
disadvantage that I should I need to
stop studying programming is what this
comes down to and I need to start
studying the other side that's my
weakness that is like just the hard math
and the hard logic so I'm pretty good
with basic logic I'm probably pretty
even even pretty good with medium we'll
say medium logic but when it gets hard
that's where I kind of drop off so but
you know it at that point when you're
you're into a concept that's so
difficult
that's so mathematically like abstract
in and has so many layers and so many
things going on it doesn't matter how
well you know the language you can't
come up with the solution because you
can't wrap your head around the solution
even if you know every bit of the
language so those are the two sides and
just some thoughts that I hope helps
them some newer programmers out there
this is something I sort of recently
fully realized I mean it's something
that kind of you kind of told but it's a
lot to try to learn everything at once
if you already have one of these skills
if you already really good at math or
logic programming comes a lot easier
like the the inventor of the a lot of
these languages the inventor of all the
early object-oriented languages and none
of those guys were programmers are
considered themselves programmers they
were just trying to come up with a
solution to the problem of how to get
these computers to work and it turned
out to be a programming language and
then the whole programming fad came
later pretty interesting stuff to think
about
hope you enjoyed this video and if you
want to see more random programming
videos random tutorials please hit the
subscribe button take it easy
and keep studying keep coding you got
this